dave ça va très très bien alors je vais
te présenter se présente ou tu te
présentes comment faire présentement as
tu me connais mieux gay et je vous
présente des chèques des chèques donc
key à la chaîne histoire brève ou en
gros c'est de l'histoire mais manière
brève serre que dans des vidéos de gros
cinq minutes ainsi comme ça en moyenne
tu prends un fait historique et tu nous
expliques mais à la cool avec des
dessins etc
c'est un peu moi ça peut enfin on a un
petit je pense dans la même mouvance
serre que l'on fait au match m sérieuse
d'éducation et tout mais on traite les
sujets vraiment à la cool sans se
prendre la tête et avec un peu de fun
quoi j'aurais dû mieux on coule et du
coup je suis dit que ce serait marrant
qu'on se pose la question ensemble de
t'imagines si hitler avait gagné la
seconde guerre mondiale outre en
question si jamais grande question
seelandais et du coup les gens on va
changer le jeu non non je te propose que
tu connais principe qu'on lise les
réponses des gens et qu'on ait soit là
qu'on rebondisse dessus qu'on en discute
quoi show avec plaisir ça marche tu
imagines si ya pas encore de génériques
mais ça arrive comme le thé japonais
je ne sais pas du combat et steve ware
est ce qu'avant que est ce que ça ne
dérangerait de faire un mini mini récap
genre histoire bref bref bref bref il
prend près de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale ou de la seconde guerre
mondiale la faje seconde guerre mondiale
classe milliard noël
ok bah en fait techniquement typiquement
il ya plusieurs fins we have environ
vers ce qui est des frais relatifs qua
non pas par natif de chivas effect tout
s'est passé
il n'y a pas de souci on n'a pas mais
dans notre réalité maintenant à notre
réalité dans la tradition pour l'europe
ouais ce qui se passe c'est que les
russes écrase les allemands de leur côté
et prennent allemagne près de berlin
hitler se suicide
pendant ce temps là les américains
débarquent en france et remonte l'europe
par l'ouest
ça c'est la faim chez nous mais c est
une guerre mondiale et de l'autre côté
du monde y avait les américains qui est
en guerre contre des japonais qui
mettait sur la tronche
lui parle à bord et du coup ben ils ont
résolu ça en lâchant deux bombes
nucléaires sur le japon auquel
auxquelles google et c'est là que la
seconde guerre mondiale se finit
vraiment alors après ça c'était genre de
bombe à ok qu'est ce qu'on fait regarde
ça suffit que voilà on a compris
typiquement après la guerre bat comme
dans toutes les guerres et des gagnants
et des perdants et les perdants
généralement pas beaucoup de choix donc
les gagnants se partagent une partie de
l'allemagne mais berlin l'allemagne est
coupée en deux les uns et il garde une
partie le bloc de l'ouest
les etats unis considèrent d'eau garde
le reste 20 20 est divisé en plusieurs
segments que les alliés s'attire les
gagnants
tartaglia et oui ça l'a lardé asselin
public démocratique d'allemagne qu'il ya
démocratique dans un pays en général
500 tient aussi bien voilà et puis la
république fédérale d'allemagne qui est
du coup la partie à tous nos copains il
ya pas mal de gens dans les commentaires
to be well cia une série qui fait déjà
ce truc là avec sa pelle de man 2 avec
castle effectivement effectivement chez
moi je n'ai pas vu du tout moi non plus
voilà donc le but et on se détache un
peu de ça on va peut-être faire des
trucs sont déjà dans la série des trucs
qui sont pas dans la série elle croître
le pitch de la série de façon c'est les
nazis qu'ils gagnent et qui ont baissé
aux états unis ou quelque chose comme ça
donc ça va un peu plus loin que nous ok
est aussi un autre livre c'est mais
cette fois celle inverse
ces genres hitler qui a été pris aux
beaux-arts et qui apparemment c'est un
très très bon livre je mettrai le
le nom dans la description je me ferait
peser que circoncision merci à boudjerra
mais même pas sûr parce que les ricains
par exemple il se pince et culturelles
traditionnelles justement pour eux ne
pas être circoncis c'est l'ultra bizarre
en fait c'est il faut demander aux
médecins de pas circoncire l'enfant
quand il ne désigne donc tu peux être
circoncis pour plein de raisons qui sont
pas du tout des raisons religieuses quoi
on répète des raisons d'hygiène machin
après à l'époque ça serait aussi des
arguments quand tu disais que tu étais
pas juif
ça va oui oui ça pouvait soirée à leur
carte de visite quoi mais ça servait de
vj ben ok mais en inde qu'en avant la
création du pakistan quand c'était quand
c'était vraiment le bordel et que les
musulmans se faisait le trucider à
l'époque ça c'est un regret aussi
d'arguments qui ont demandé aux banques
de baisser leur froc qui existait sur
concile
c'était fini ah ouais ouais show bad
racisme vu que l'humanité serait composé
que de blancs d'oeufs beau compromis
entre les idées de gauche et de droite
et éclaire resterait dans l'histoire
comme en transe unificateur qui
resterait dans l'histoire comme un
groupe significatif s'il avait gagné oui
de toute façon mais après l'humanité
certains à l'europe après tad racisme
bailly serai toujours là avec les autres
existera encore en fait ouais il aurait
fallu qu'il éradique tous les peuples
mais même toit à moi je pense qu'il ya
des couches oui c'est pas que de risquer
une couleur de peau quand même les
italiens les fins les espagnols en
france à une certaine époque ça va dans
la doctrine sisters d'autres façons y
avait des classifications entre les
races wen et même entre les blancs les
latins et en dessous des germaniques et
slaves aussi pour eux ce qu'ils avaient
pour lui ce qu'ils avaient au dessus
tout c'était donc les germaniques donc
les scandinaves les allemands eon et
après ça commence à descendre partir de
la boucle et cela à temps
je vais faire mon eagle pour le coup je
pense qu'une victoire d'hitler n'aurait
pas changé grand chose à l'histoire à
l'échelle macroscopique de l'histoire
selon moi l'histoire les quinze cycle
dans n'est qu'une question de cycles de
motifs archétypique similaire qui
reviennent à l'infini sitter avait gagné
il aurait été une sorte de césar ou
napoléon
on sait bien comment les duos ont fini
la contingence de l'histoire fait que
tout a un début une croissance un déclin
et une femme donc jusqu'à la mort
d'hitler
ça aurait été le bordel après on serait
revenu une sorte de siècle de réformes
et de nouvelle constitution comme le 19e
siècle après napoléon et à certains
égards
j'ose dire que ça aurait même eu du bon
de tout reprendre à zéro
je sais pas si ça aurait eu du bon de
tout reprendre je pense qu'effectivement
mai et puis ya des manières de tout
rebond à 0 c'est ça typiquement dans le
cul aussi faire que bien pierre en fait
oui c'est bien mieux
ou bien mieux je comprends ce qu'il dit
genre le coût des cycles exit a
effectivement tué à napoléon d'ailleurs
on nous avait parlé ensemble
chase que moi j'avais un peu une image
d'un mec assez stylé to machine est en
route je lui en parlerai que toi rendu
compte que c'était un peu un dictateur
aussi le gagnant est ce que est ce que
on n'aurait pas eu ce point de vue là
sur éclair en hausse 1
oui et non parce que fin de son vivant
et il ya eu quarantaine de complot pour
l'assassiner
le mec s'en est sorti à chaque fois mais
les gars autour de lui voler le but est
pas que ce qui ne changera forcément cas
de deux avec niang et amazon aussi s'ils
ont tous su wei hitler d'accord sur la
france ça devenait vraiment c'est ça ça
passe que par napoléon c'était un
dirigeant classique pour l'époque c'est
juste qu'il a été une échelle vraiment
énorme ce qui a entraîné normalement de
mort mais dans le style c'est du
classique c'est du déjà vu et il y en a
eu avant il y en a eu après alors que
hitler comme staline les mecs ont causé
des millions et des millions de morts
sur des réflexions pas forcément charlie
si j'oserais dire en fait là bruno
est ce que napoléon c'était moins
idéologique on peut dire que c'était
moins idéologique ce sens on sait ça en
fait tous que staline d'ailleurs au
final ce que staline à face elle a
devancé la russe dans une idée de
conquête
c'est ça ça la gloire de la nation aussi
les gens peuvent se retrouver là dedans
wade l'ère technologique presque perso
non mais ça l'est de lever avec un grand
axe était attachant mais qui est pas
forcément lié à la fin la gloire de
l'allemagne est passée à faire cette
idéologie la wii voilà c'était c'était
une excuse aussi c'était pour redonner
sa gloire à l'allemagne qui avait été
rabaissé par tous les autres pays autour
après la première guerre mondiale à
cause du traité je sais plus ouais enfin
c'est quand ils ont tous redécouper
qu'ils ont dit qu allemagne les ouates
mils muliaina tout le monde quoi avec du
coup ça fait s'effondrer le pays
cette thèse à la eagle et fiction
sénégal il a une thèse comme quoi tu as
genre l'histoire c'est tout sont
cycliques star ac en fait c'est toujours
la même chose et éventuellement
prévisible voilà et c'est un maintien
est en fait il ya une contre thèse à ça
japonais qui lui dit qu'en fait le
capitalisme a mené la fin de l'histoire
parce qu'en fait ça fait que vu qu'il ya
une interdépendance entre tous les états
et c'est un machin et que maintenant on
a on a la paix via l'économie en fait eh
ben ça ça marque un arrêt à cette liste
à cette histoire cyclique de guerre d'
eurobonds et c'est quand y réfléchit les
pays qui sont dans cette boucle du
cookie échanges se font pas la guerre
entre eux du coup il peut y avoir des
tensions nomme avec la russie mais au
final c'est les pics hors de la boucle
qui sont déjà dans des états critiques
en fait qui se font la guerre ou chez
qui on va perdre la guerre
mais entre nous c'est vrai qu'on sera au
final pendant la guerre froide c'était
déjà ça on se mettait pas sur la tronche
entre nous entre les deux blocs
on s'est mariés mais on l'a fait aussi
économiquement la guerre faisait via
deux guerres c'est ça et puis comme dit
ça c'est aussi très économiquement la
guerre que ce soit à coups de contrats
d'arrangements
culturellement aussi énormément enfin
tout ce qui sauf peur on va dire ce qui
est important c'est ce qui est militaire
la puissance vraiment dur voilà dur
physique et/ou skillsoft power s'être
économiques culturels s'être la
puissance d'une nation le rayonnement
d'une nation par plein d'autres biais
qui sont pas des billets militaires
techniciens au kényan a du coup la
caméra depuis seulement en fait il est
beaucoup trop bas
ben ouais ça passe il ya un gros message
de huy brayson cie clair et donc le
troisième reich avait gagné la troisième
guerre mondiale
ça veut dire la seconde je pense que je
pense l'urss serait tombé vu que c'est
grâce à elle et au front est que le
front ouest et nord africains ont pu
tenir et avancer à partir de 44 donc les
scientifiques russes et nazis auraient
mis au point beaucoup plus rapidement
que les américains un programme spatial
vers les us ont pu rester dans la course
grâce aux travaux allemand de waremme
von braun
mais quel est donc suprématie allemande
avec les missiles à longue portée
donc pas de guerre froide donc moins de
bordel au moyen-orient entre parenthèses
cia qui arme les rebelles contre les
dirigeants pro communiste où la chaîne
youtube déjà non mais je n'en fais pas
ça mais connaissant les projets de kim
leur ce serait retour l esclavage avec
une énorme séparation des richesses le
japon aurait eu le soutien allemand dans
le pacifique donc plus rien pour les
contrer et à cette époque les japonais
ce n'était pas drôle rigolo il suffit de
voir les massacres perpétrés par l'armée
japonaise dans toute la chine
le monde serait disputée entre le japon
et l'allemagne et l'ambiance n'aurait
pas été à la liberté d'expression
ça n'aurait pas été charrié ça c'est sûr
on n'est pas si mal que ça quand même
au début il ya le truc sur la course à
l'armement oui alors ça ça typiquement
oui puisque au final mais c'est en
récupérant plein de scientifiques nazis
mais que les américains ont pu booster
leur programme spécial bons d'achat
n'est pas du tout peut-être que oui il
doit envoyer des gens dans l'espace
largement à vendre tout ce qui est
missiles v2
joie c'était développement à la base et
qui du coup est arrivé aux etats unis le
programme en excuser c'est juste un gros
missiles qui explose pas quand tout va
bien le coup du bordel au moyen-orient
parce que c'est assez acquis à mais les
rebelles contre le dirigeant pro
communistes ça je sais pas très bien
parce qu'on imagine pour lui et 40 à
guerre froide en fait voilà parce qu'il
ya un moment en fait on sera arrivé un
statu quo je pense ce que les américains
ont pas non plus envie de passer leur
vie ici ça être la seule à défendre
publiquement et les mecs sont loin c'est
à dire qu'il faut traverser l'océan et
c'est vrai - que les gars développe des
fusées que les auteurs en face et qui
dément barre des espaces de la carte
mais je pense qu'on sera une espèce de
star et surtout inquiète les américains
ils n'ont pas utilisé la les
scientifiques nazis dans une ba est ce
qu'on les américains les ont utilisées
pour faire les bombes nucléaires non ça
juste derrière et ils ont huit cents ça
c'est le projet manhattan qui date qui a
commencé avant la guerre en fait au
caire entre ce qu'il recherche nucléaire
qu'il aurait donc de toute façon même
s'il est clair aller gagner à son guerre
mondiale les américains ont eu la bombe
nucléaire
voilà il aurait pu il aurait au final
s'il évolue il aurait aussi pu faire
péter l'europe en fait un ticket pense
que c'est une bombe du coup c'est par un
missile
c'est donc en gros les les allemandes
enfin les nazis n'auraient pas eu la
mainmise enfin n'aurait pas été
surpuissant par rapport aux usa et donc
il aurait eu possiblement cette guerre
froide ça s'arrache que pour le coup les
nazis eux n'avaient pas leur venue faire
mais ça fait bien un avantage de taille
quand les américains sont servis au
japon c'est un peu montré au reste du
monde ce dont ils étaient capables
ça calme c'est un peu usage principal d
1 milliard aujourd'hui donc la guerre
froide elle aurait pu continuer à faire
il y aurait pu y avoir une guerre froide
totalement effectivement les japonais
s'était pas de jaux le rigolo ça
voudrait qu'à taper dans google unité
731 allait pas voir les images
c'est lé pas voir les images mais juste
si on peut écouter de lire les
descriptions la description wikipedia ça
calme en fait elle est juste au sahara
au niveau expérience au vivisection et
stérilisés un cran devant les albums oui
comment s'appelle mecque l'un des wem et
guay lui fait bad et déjà oui mais
aujourd'hui mais c'était bien aux siens
au genre de truc avec de l'acide et ou
machin ils ont vraiment fait tout et
n'importe quoi afin qu il ya des
sections sur des gens vivent enfin ça le
faisait au sien mais difficile
vivisection du coup mais kryptos il va
checker cette fameuse ils étaient 60
créateurs
tu verras c'est très sympa le point de
godwin n'existerait pas ni toute la
mythologie du nazi dans l'appart culture
à ce serait moins drôle
ou alors quelqu'un on retrouve un truc
pierre a fait rentrer tant que tel point
qu'au but est que tout le monde c'est
parce que c'est là le point godwin
en gros c'est un point qui arrive c'est
quand dans une discussion on arrive au
moment où on parle est clair c'est en
gros l'idée dans un débat la discussion
ben en fait il me semble que la théorie
c'est que dans n'importe quelle
discussion
au bout d'un moment si la discussion est
infini au bout d'un moment tu parles
d'hitler et c'est normal parce que c'est
un souvent on prend des exemples plutôt
extrêmes pour illustrer très rapidement
un point c'est vachement utile dans la
discussion c'est de prendre un extrait
me dira mais tu vois l'idée ce que je
veux dire c'est regarde si on pousse à
l'extrême ça donne ça et donc on veut
pas te tiens donc c'est le point de
donner mais parce qu'on serait dans ce
système où c'est accepter en fait parce
que dans un système où ça serait pas un
truc extrêmes le niveau là c'est normal
je serai là larmes après bien et entre
une question qu'on peut se poser aussi
c'est un site l'arrêté morts enfin et
qu'on a avancé
l'info n'est voilà les nazis ont gagné
les nazis ont gagné et claire crème le
temps est passé
t'imagines si ringard ultra poser arrive
au pouvoir en allemagne à l'époque et du
coup bah oui soit poseurs poseurs voilà
on va l'appeler poseurs on va l'appeler
poseurs et oz l'air dans la main qui
font du coup et que le méchant dans
mario cas pas avoir honte
donc ben voilà qu'en parlant justement
c'est là où je veux en venir capa tu
n'as pas compris champions continue tu
veux des tuyaux pour pour reprendre sans
rigoler
au dire ça j'ai fait un tri faut que les
rifains faut qu'on trouve un angle son
qu'elle tape et ouais ouais j'aurais
claus velte était un truc ça
si nous avons les américains ouais il
aura fallu que il ya un truc dans la
discussion qui après ses conseillers
américains avaient quand même marqué mon
but car sur le japon ouais j'avoue moi
ya eu le problème rénaux le point zéro a
enfin annoncé combien mankowski beaudry
n'est pas hitler non c'est le nom qui a
trouvé ces mecs 4k et murray aurait
peut-être g il y aurait peut-être lui
pardonner l'économie a dépensé ça
s'appellerait comme le guen et puis
voilà si on était passé à autre chose en
fait je serais peut-être passé en tout
dont on parle pas en fait le moment où
on a exterminé 6 millions de personnes
ouais tu vois c'est comme ceux comme la
france avec un collabo voilà où les
collabos ou à ce qui s'est passé en
algérie ou devenir ou la goujaterie qui
auront demain voilà on n'assume pas
toujours les conneries qu'on a fait en
général quand on sort vainqueur on
attend ça mais ça de côté et apprendre
autre chose à l'école de toute façon
tout aurait été comme dans le roi lion
alors dans le royaume appartient quelle
partie des ouailles en terre quand s'il
reste ou dans la jungle et que du coup
la terre des lions totalement desséché
qui fait qu'il ya de l'orage tout le
temps et que les gaines
dominé les lions dessert car en gros ce
quart gagne et c'est à dire qu'il ya un
petit enfant de l'europe qui survit sa
source de gaulle gens fuient va plus
loin que londres diva aux us ouais c'est
simba de gaulle il rencontre donc si
vous voulez pouvoir ce serait des
ricains timon et pumbaa ce serait
eisenhower et et un mot triquint ou la
diva s'est levé il redonne du peps
ouais et ensuite qui revient un jt
revient et nous libère et il prend avec
la roma noam a new way
il nous fait c'est quoi ta non non il
l'envoie en arrière c'est ça en fait il
plus rien qui va aimer et ensuite les
iem le beauf pense qu'ils se sont rendus
compte qu hitler les avait trahis du
coup on fait il ya donc en fait les
cartons ray chez les soviétiques par
exemple tu vois oui oui et le gameplay
[ __ ] mon gars en fait le roi lion
hockey des jeux télé père cool c'était
hyper cool de t'avoir car ça va plus ça
passe avant c'était vraiment cool cool
ça fait plaisir en plus vous vous sentez
pas il ya une petite chaleur si dans un
sens la cheminée perd on est très très
bien là on est très très bien bah ça
fait plaisir le plaisir était partagé ça
fait vachement plaisir
si vous connaissez pas d envoi allait
voir sa chaîne c'est du très bon taf je
vois commandes à fond on se revoit j'ai
alors je sais pas quand est-ce qu'on
on va se revoir avec qui et quels
invités mais je vous mets la question
répondent au désir tout de suite dans
les commentaires la de cette vidéo
la question de la voilà t'imagines si on
vous pouvez faire l'amour qu'une seule
fois dans sa vie avec la chaîne parlons
peu parlons cul et ont fait de gros
bisous love peace chao et entités
tchèques s'en voit tous ses pôles des
tchèques en fait donc fait un check
parce qu'en fait son homme s'était
tchèque voilà et du coup quand tu payes
tu paies avec dol de la monnaie ou du
check check plutôt mon personnage
préféré dans zelda c'est cheikh mahfoud
prochaine grosse partie des privilèges
qui les a tués à cech déjà ou non avec
reste précieux fonds permanent on vous
dit un petit chèque en france de venir
voler si maman